i was lucky enough
to be working at one of the best
companies in the world focused on being
a practicing engineer and was designing
one of the very first pentium generation
computer chips which was
just such a great opportunity but if i
wanted to sort of grow and manage and
have more input on the larger road map
of
not just that chip project but overall
chip projects and
eventually lead other engineers and
other projects
i knew i needed to get a technical
degree so when i discovered that through
the stanford center for professional
development
i could actually do these classes
remotely
and i could sort of you know construct
my own pathway through the degree
program
but still taking regular classes the
same ones that are taught on campus
and i'd be taking them with residential
students and even working with those
students in projects
i wasn't going to be sort of siloed off
or whatever it felt like a no-brainer
there were actually a bunch of other
students remote as well
and so i was getting exposed to them as
well as the on-campus students
and the mix of that was really powerful
so the highlight of
my time doing my graduate program
work through stanford center for
professional development was a class
called global project coordination
at that time it was actually at t had a
global logistics supply chain
challenge that they wanted help with it
was really the first time that i'd
experienced
taking a project all the way from start
to finish with a team
that's distributed not just one remote
person
and then everyone else in the same place
literally in four or five different
locations
throughout the entire quarter working on
something real
and we actually delivered a great
solution that the company implemented
taking that one class set me on a path
over the last 20 years where i literally
built my own venture capital firm
so that i could fund resources and
investment
to these kinds of entrepreneurs remotely
in the u.s and increasingly around the
world
i do teach a regular course here to
students which by the way
as you would expect my course includes
equally residential students and remote
students
whether they're on campus or whether
they're somewhere else always have this
component of how do we bridge
different regions different industries
different cultures
different you know economic
systems even so that people can learn
from each other
not only from the exchange of ideas but
more importantly
to create that network and that almost
culture of support so that they know
they're not alone and that's really what
silicon valley
has become and continues to become when
i say it's a network and not just
a place there's something special about
stanford that we haven't yet figured out
how to make available anywhere else
without first kind of
getting a little exposure here that's
why i always do advocate that people
you know ground their experience of
learning and connection here
but then take that wherever they want to
take it